what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some news about New Mutants
not the New Mutants but new Mutant
characters and new X-Men characters
coming to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
now we know that Deadpool 3 is going to
bring back some old X-Men characters
some of the original X-Men such as Ian
McKellen's Magneto Patrick Stewart's
Professor Xavier who has already really
been brought back anyways in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness but
other iconic characters are going to be
returning as well but new characters new
X-Men are also going to be introduced in
Deadpool 3 Deadpool 3's filming is
taking place right now and also side
note about Deadpool 3 filming right now
deadline reported that they should be
wrapping up filming by next month
apparently this is incorrect according
to The Insider my time to shine hello
Deadpool 3 is going to be filming until
September which makes a lot of sense
because Deadpool 3 just started filming
a lot of people were wondering well how
exactly is dead pull 3 going to be
finished filming so quickly when they
just started and a lot of people were
worried about that but it looks like we
don't have to worry too much now a lot
of people were worried that they were
just going to be using reused footage
from previous Fox films like the X-Men
and Deadpool Etc and we'll talk about
that in just a bit in this video because
they are going to do some of that but
not all it's only going to be for a
brief part of the movie and we'll
explain in just a bit we'll also
announce the giveaway winner at the end
of this video now from what we've
already learned about Deadpool 3
Deadpool is going to be working with the
TVA as sort of a punishment instead of
just getting pruned by the TBA they're
going to essentially contract him to
help them fix or eliminate a universe
that was not supposed to exist and
Deadpool is the one who caused this
universe to exist basically by the
actions that he did at the end of
Deadpool 2 slash what he's going to do
at the beginning of Deadpool 3. just to
jog your memory if you don't remember or
if you haven't seen it at the end of
Deadpool 2 Deadpool took Cable's time
travel device and essentially messed up
some timelines he killed off some
characters and he intentionally did this
Prime examples he went back and killed
his old self in the old Fox Universe the
old Deadpool the one that we don't
really talk about there's a reason that
he killed him
foreign
scratch
just cleaning up the timelines look
eventually you're gonna hang up the
claws and it's gonna make a lot of
people very sad huh but one day your old
pal Wade's gonna ask you to get back in
the saddle again
and when he does say yes
oh right these events are apparently
what is going to create a universe where
Magneto is the ruler of the universe now
we've heard about this before but we
didn't know how exactly it happened
apparently Deadpool going back in the
past killing himself in front of
Wolverine has a massive effect and
causes an old Fox X-Men Universe to
collide with a newer MCU universe so if
you thought the Cameo potential for
Deadpool 3 was already insane well it
just got a lot more insane we could see
some cameos from the MCU now this will
mean we'll get more interactions of
characters from the MCU with characters
from the old Fox X-Men universe and not
just the X-Men universe but maybe some
of you have heard that Ben Affleck is
going to be in Deadpool 3 as well now we
are assuming that he is going to be
playing Daredevil since that's the role
that he played before so it seems like
this movie is going to have cameos
Galore old cameos at least with a little
bit of new but we'll talk about that in
just a bit and apparently from what
we've heard and this is not 100
confirmed but just a little leak slash
rumor that's been going on out there
about Deadpool 3 is that this universe
that Deadpool created by killing himself
in a timeline and possibly doing other
things with Wolverine since we know
Wolverine is going to be one of the main
characters got off its normal course
which in turn collided with another
universe that got off course and this
universe is a part of the MCU it's
actually going to be a branch of the
main timeline that was created by Tony
Stark and Steve Rogers going back in
time to receive the Mind Stone this
timeline is apparently going to
intersect with another Deadpool X-Men
timeline giving us the universe where
Magneto rules over all and he has
successfully created a universe where
pretty much everyone is a mutant and
there's a rumor going around that in
this universe Magneto possibly
successfully created the conversion
machine turning people into mutants or
are at least activating the mutant genes
inside of people everybody else he could
possibly kill off normal humans and this
is where we are going to see that X-Men
lineup that we've been talking about
however if this is truly combined with
an MCU timeline then we could see two
possible things happening in Deadpool 3
one we could actually see a battle of
the Avengers vs the X-Men The Avengers
vs the X-Men was a very huge comic event
it was Game changing and if you haven't
read it I highly suggest you do so and
of course it won't be adapted page for
page but we could possibly get that with
Magneto's world because he has an X-Men
team and if everybody else that isn't an
X-Men or a mutant is killed well that
probably means that he goes up against
the Avengers and if he's going up
against Captain America and Iron Man and
Thor well Magneto definitely has the
upper hand there being able to control
metal plus if he has a whole X-Men team
to help them go up against these people
The Avengers that is I definitely have
to say that it goes to Magneto and
professor X and whoever else is on the
team so one of the things we could see
is a possible flashback to the Avengers
losing and possibly dying to the X-Men
and if you do want to check out the
Avengers vs X-Men be sure to check out
my buddies over at comicbookdirect.com
they have created a website and company
that makes comic book shopping the
easiest it can possibly be they deliver
Comics straight to your door you can get
one-off Comics or you can sign up for an
entire run and get a pretty big discount
if you do so and they'll ship the latest
issue right to your door each week they
have the latest from Marvel if you're
trying to keep up to date with all the
recent projects they have the latest
from DC as well and it's an all-in-one
shop for your Comics everything that you
need in one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now we don't want to go too
off the rails with the possible cameos
that we could get in Deadpool 3 but we
already know we're going to be seeing
some amazing cameos like the possible
Return of the Fantastic 4 including
Chris Evans as the Human Torch like I
mentioned Ben Affleck is rumored to be
coming back most of the original X-Men
are rumored to be coming back as well
but now we're hearing that new X-Men
characters that have never been
introduced before in any Universe could
possibly make their debuts in this film
as well in fact according to some recent
rumors Channing Tatum could possibly and
finally the plane Gambit now we did have
a Gambit before in the old Fox universe
so perhaps due to some incursions or
Deadpool change in the timeline a little
bit it ends up being Channing Tatum
playing Gambit since it's a Multiverse
movie there is going to be a bit of fan
service and really that's just going to
come in the form of cameos now I don't
want to over hype this like we did for
Multiverse of Madness because we want to
level our expectations and honestly Hugh
Jackman returning as Wolverine is good
enough for us it's more than good enough
it's fantastic that and seeing some
original X-Men return is just amazing as
well throw in some cameos for old
characters as well like Ben Affleck's
Daredevil and then throw in some new
X-Men that we've never seen before this
movie should be fantastic providing the
plot is solid but Deadpool working with
the TVA because he was messing with time
travel is a good story that ties into
the MCU extremely well and also ties
into Avengers Secret Wars extremely well
and Ryan Reynolds has been working on
the script for a very very long time so
you know he's put a lot of care into it
so if you have any awesome cameos that
you would love to see let us know who
you'd like to see in the comments down
below who do you want to see pop up
whether it's a new character or an old
character also big congratulations to
YouTube user Jason Murdoch 9254 for
being the giveaway winner of June I sent
you a message be sure to check it and
don't forget we're doing another
giveaway we do one each month so the
July giveaway has started if you want to
enter for a chance to win an Xbox series
X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items or
some DC items all you gotta do is
subscribe and leave a comment on any of
our videos in July you can also support
the channel further by checking out our
patreon account our Discord server and
our website and of course you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as well as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign